Ja alle diejenigen von euch schon mal die tosende brandung des meeres mehr in live betrachtet haben die kölner an
welche unendliche kraft hinter den wellen stellt liegt doch nahe dass man den ozean als einen gigantischen
stromlieferanten nutzen könnte gerade läuft der härtetest für ein neues
wellenkraftwerk vor schottland und das ist echt nicht ohne wie genau können allein die
wellenbewegungen des meeres zur energiegewinnung dienen und was sind die herausforderungen
herzlich willkommen bei klick zum science fiction
Ihr habt euch bei whatsapp genau dieses thema gewünscht und hier ist es das was da im
nordatlantik schwimmt sieht nur auf den ersten blick aus wie eine bohrinsel
tatsächlich aber handelt es sich um einen prototypen eines neuen wellenkraftwerk es anders als bei den sogenannten gezeitenkraftwerken
wird hierbei nicht die energie des wassers bei flut und ebbe genutzt also der unterschied zwischen den beiden niveaus um turbinen anzutreiben
stattdessen soll der wellengang an sich zur energiegewinnung genutzt werden diese wasser bewegung ist in einigen
meeresgebieten tatsächlich so hoch dass das funktionieren kann physikalisch gesehen
wird die energie in den wellen in form potenzieller lager energie und in form von bewegungsenergie
der wasser partikel gespeichert schätzung zufolge kann die energiedichte bis zu
1000 kilowatt pro meter seitenlänge einer welle erreichen wobei tiefere gewässer eine höhere energiedichte
aufweisen als flache es gibt studien nach denen das physikalische potenzial der wellenenergie weltweit auf bis zu zehn
terawatt geschätzt wird das ist echt nicht ohne der name des neuen wellen kraftwerks vor den schottischen orkney islands
der laute c3 wellenenergie
konverter und er soll deutlich
effektiver sein als alles was vor ihm die meeresenergie in strom umwandeln konnte konkret besteht der wellenenergie
converter aus
einer schwimmenden boje die von den wellen im wasser hoch und runter schaubild um genau diese auf und abbewegung wird dann von einer gezähmten
schiene und eine art getriebe in eine drehbewegung
umgewandelt und damit wird der generator dann endlich eingetrieben nach angaben des
internationalen
forschungsteams waren die tests im labor mehr als erfolgreich der neue prototyp kann demnach fünfmal mehr energie pro tonne erzeugen als andere
wellenkraft systeme das gelingt wohl vor allem durch ein 8 teiliges kaskaden getriebe dass die kraft der wellen bewegung effektiv und
gleichmäßig auf den generator überträgt zudem
sorgen dämpfer dafür dass das system nicht überlastet wird denn die kraft der wellen ist nicht zu unterschätzen
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher stephan björklund diese flexiblen einsätze sind entscheiden denn sie ermöglichen die
gleichmäßige verteilung der last und schützen das getriebe gegen schocks doch die dämpfer sorgen auch dafür dass das system setzt bei
extremem wellengang effizient läuft und die wellenbewegungen in eine schnelle drehung der zahnräder
umgewandelt werden kann und die praxis bedingungen sind wirklich hart für den neuen wellenkraft generator die region von den orkney islands
die ist nicht ohne der wellengang ist extrem hoch und die gezeiten sehr stark zudem
befindet sich vor ort ein schwimmendes stromnetz zu versuchszwecken genau deswegen haben wir schon einige forschungsteams ihre
wellenkraftwerke in der praxis getestet werden durch die anbindung an das stromnetz können die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler herausfinden ob die boje funktioniert kann sie also tatsächlich
elektrischen strom mit einer stabilen frequenz und spannung erzeugen
falls der konverter diesem test besteht wird das forschungsteam dieses system vergrößern und es dann noch einmal langfristig
testen doch solch eine boje ist nur eines der zahlreichen konzepte zur nutzung von wellen energie zudem gibt es auch
speicherbecken mit einer verengten zufluss rinne die sorgt dafür dass die wellen an höhe gewinnen und oberhalb des
meeresspiegels in das becken treten über eine turbine
wird es ins meer zurück geleitet und die energie kann genutzt werden außerdem gibt es auch anlagen mit einer
oszillierende wassersäule am meeresgrund befindet sich eine kamera der steigende wasserspiegel lässt die
darüberliegende luftsäule durch eine turbine strömen die immer in dieselbe drehrichtung
beschleunigt wird egal wie die strömungsrichtung der luft ist optimale standorte dafür sind beispielsweise die küsten spaniens
irlands oder norwegens und er könnte es schon vorstellen es gibt
einige vorteile solcher konzepte es wird kein wasser verbraucht und es gibt keinerlei
abfälle zudem wird auf die natur und umwelt nicht sehr stark beeinflusst doch wie bei vielen anderen arten der erneuerbaren
energien gibt es keine regelmäßigkeit bei der stromerzeugung
gleich ist diese unregelmäßigkeit nicht ganz so schlimm wie bei windkraftwerken denn das mehr
bewegt sich immer aber die wellen stärken die es eben immer unterschiedlich und nimmt keine rücksicht darauf ob gerade viel strom im netz
benötigt wird oder nicht es werden also auch hier puffer wie batterie farben gebraucht zudem sind auch die kosten für die investitionen in
wellenkraftwerke noch vergleichsweise
hoch ja mal sehen ob sich diese technik durchsetzen kann wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht denn die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst kam video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir immer vom neuesten video und zwar
vorab täglich vor allen anderen und das garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
was geht hier da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt einfach draufklicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken die lüge der energiewende bis dann
bleibt dran